this is tomor hussein reading for
reviewer andrew king
12 minutes is the time loop story
reduced to its very essence it is spare
in length and small in scope taking
place almost entirely within a one
bedroom apartment
but that smallness contains narrative
and mechanical multitudes that pay off
consistently over the course of 12
minutes is six hour run time there's
somebody breaking into my apartment he's
got a gun and he's gonna kill me and my
wife
sending a unit right now get to a safe
place i say almost entirely because as
the game begins its unnamed protagonist
voiced by james mcavoy rides the
elevator up to their apartment the
hallway between the elevator and the
apartment door aerially carpeted with
the autumnal pattern from the shining
overlook hotel serves as a brief
tutorial
learn to navigate from the game's top
down perspective find a fake rock in the
potted plant outside the apartment use
the fake rock to find the key within
take the key and use it on the door it's
a short but effective introduction to
the point and click style mechanics on
display here 12 minutes is mechanically
rich because it leans into this
old-school kind of adventuring that
encourages creative thinking there
aren't many objects in the apartment but
those that are there can often be
combined in fun and surprising ways
once inside the apartment our
protagonist is greeted by his wife
voiced by daisy ridley who has set out
some fake candles prepared dessert and
wrapped a present it's a romantic
evening but there's a storm brewing just
outside that weather event which your
character will take note of if you
interact with any of the windows in the
apartment is a fitting metaphor for the
turn your pleasant evening is about to
take
midway through dinner a mysterious man
played by willem dafoe shows up at the
door claiming to be police you can let
him in or wait for him to kick down the
door no matter what you do he will enter
your apartment bind you both with flex
cuffs and kill you
then the loop restarts and you're
stumbling into your apartment warmly lit
for that romantic dinner you'll never
get to finish jesus christ the apartment
is small believably so in a way that
fictional apartments really are and is
composed of four rooms a primary space
which does triple duty as living room
kitchen and dining room a bedroom a
bathroom and a coat closet there are a
few items that seem to have obvious
utility like a knife on the counter and
a bottle of sleeping pills in the
bathroom cabinet but most exist in an
intriguing gray area
is there a reason i should study that
framed art print on the wall does this
dessert exist only to be eaten could the
book on meditation that the wife is
reading possibly have any purpose beyond
characterization in a traditional
point-and-click adventure game these
questions could easily lead to annoyance
the kind of frustration that comes from
trying every item on every other item
until something finally works i never
found myself giving in to this impulse
while playing 12 minutes the environment
is so small and well considered and
loops so brief that i really went longer
than a few minutes without thinking up
something new to try the top-down
perspective reveals an environment that
is so small and starkly empty that as
each new layer of the story is unveiled
it almost feels like magic like wait
there's more in this one bedroom
apartment that i've scoured every inch
of how
12 minutes is use of lighting
contributes to this feeling at one point
the bedroom might be brightly lit enter
again and the room has gone dark with
blue nocturnal tones later it's bathed
in an eerie red this dynamism helps to
solve the idea that this small space
contains multitudes just as there are
new shades revealed through the shifting
light so too are their shades to this
story they have always been present in
12 minutes is loop but can only be
discovered by tilting your head in a new
direction by focusing your vision on a
neglected dusty corner there are similar
shades in the performances from mcavoy
ridley and defoe that celebrity lineup
helped gain this indie game outside the
tension but the hollywood stars never
feel like a distraction and their strong
performances imbue the game with
unexpected poignancy as the protagonist
mcavoy has the bulk of the lines and he
does a good job of selling his
character's desperation in the face of
unbelievable events the story takes
surprising wrenching turns and mcavoy
sells the emotional anguish of his
protagonist while also hitting the
necessary light notes in smaller moments
ridley similarly sells us on her
character's shock and anger while also
managing to be playful when the script
calls for it and default is believably
menacing as the cop though his
performance too contains depths that are
revealed slowly over the course of a
play through there are real moments of
sadness and pathos here the trio could
have easily felt like distracting stunt
casting but each brings real commitment
to the material you may have noticed
that none of these characters have names
though the intruder and the wife are
characters they are also objects to be
played against other objects items to be
used to potentially break the time loop
because of this some of the turns that
the story takes can feel a little
contrived as though developer luis
antonio is making do with limited toys
in a tiny toy box there are only so many
configurations this trio of characters
can take and as a result i found myself
mixed on the shocking twists the game
moves through on its route to the
conclusion that said the journey there
is still well worth taking warren
spector director of deus ex has said
that he would like to make a game
focused entirely on one city block
because the small space would allow for
unmatched mechanical depth 12 minutes
reduces specters sculpt further and
finds a rich vein for interaction and
storytelling the game may limit its loop
to 12 minutes but i found myself wishing
i could stay there for much much longer
this is a mistake
babe will you tell us
this is a misunderstanding you're under
arrest for your father's murder eight
years ago
no no that can't be right shut up my
hands you know what this is now where's
your father's watch my father